Hi, I'm Erik Voss and Wonder Woman was
one of the most enjoyable superhero
movies in recent years. I feel like a big
reason for that is the music. Like, a lot
of superhero movie themes these days
tend to blend together, but Wonder
Woman's badass cameo and new theme song in Batman vs Superman last year
definitely saved the day and some would
say maybe saved the whole movie.
And in this video, I'm going to break
down why exactly this music is so
effective, and how exactly the team
behind wonder woman used it to elevate the
film as a whole. So, it all started back
in the early days of developing Batman
vs Superman. Hans Zimmer and Junkie XL returned to compose the score for the
movie. They also composed Man of Steel
and the Christopher Nolan Dark Knight
trilogy. Now, these two guys are
responsible for composing new distinct
themes for Batman and Wonder Woman, and Zimmer said that since pretty much every
superhero movie that came before had
been so masculine and male-generated, he
wanted Wonder Woman's melody to be more uniquely feminine. Specifically, he said
that he was looking for something that
sounded like a banshee wail. And after a
hundred thousand experiments that went
wrong he turned to his friend, Tina Guo,
who plays the electric cello. Zimmer
described Guo as a version of Wonder
Woman herself. In conversation she's
elegant, regal and polite, but when she
picks up her cello, all hell breaks loose.
He compared her performance actually to
a warrior, holding the cello like a sword.
Tina Guo actually used this comparison
as inspiration for a music video that
she recently released for the Wonder
Woman theme, which was originally titled
issue with you in the Batman vs Superman
soundtrack. Check out how Guo moves with so much aggression and power. The colors
of blue and red evoke the colors of
Wonder Woman's armor. And notice how they
covered her skin in clay for these
close-ups. Guo said that this was an
intentional nod to Diana's creation
story - she was crafted from clay. So, Guo
was kind of an actress herself in this
song. She injects so much passion and
fury into the melody. So, when Wonder
Woman comes to the rescue mid-battle in
Batman vs Superman, the electric cello
follows her like a screaming Banshee
war cry.
But, when you break down this riff
melodically, there may be an even deeper
reason it's such a rallying fight song.
Notice that this melody is composed of
four notes E G B B-flat, that creates
dissonance, then resolving a half step
higher back to a B. Now if this sounds
kind of familiar to you, that's because
it's kind of similar to the progression
used in Led Zeppelin's immigrant song.
Robert Plant's opening wail uses this
same technique of dissonance to
resolution, bending from a C, a half step
higher, to a C-sharp.
And yeah, over the years immigrant song
has become so iconic that we often
associate Plant's electric wail as a
universal voice of unleashed fury.
Most recently, the song was used in the
trailer for Thor Ragnarok, where it was
associated with the arrival of another
fierce female warrior with mythological
origins, Hela. But, this song has also been
associated with a ton of badass ladies
over the years. In 2011, the trailer and
opening title sequence of David
Fincher's Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
featured a cover of immigrant song by
Karen O from the Yeah Yeah Yeah's.
But there's also a scene in the third Shrek
movie when Snow White sings immigrant
song while deploying woodland creatures
on her enemies. Now to be clear here, the
idea of dissonance and resolution is
another way of saying tension and
release, which yeah, is something that
appears in a lot of musical melodies.
Here it's used to suspend us in the
state of disorder and unrest just long
enough until we reset on the other side.
Either way, I don't think this is a
situation where Zimmer and Junkie and
Guo stole this melody; it's actually
pretty different. This isn't like when
Vanilla Ice sampled the bass line of
Queen's Under Pressure for Ice Ice Baby.
Actually, you know, maybe there is
a difference there? What do you think, Vanilla Ice? "We sampled them from them, but it's not the same bass line.
Like it goes
ding-ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding-ding.
That's the way there's goes. Ours goes
ding-ding-ding-ding ding-ding-ding-ding."
Um, actually no. Nice try.
I think the Wonder Woman theme just
echoes immigrants song in an interesting
way, and it's because that tension and
release of a high-pitched note triggers
a specific emotion in us. And I think
that emotion is called...
Oh, sh*t! But the movie of Wonder Woman
features its own original score composed
by Rupert Gregson-Williams,
and Williams wanted to feature this
melody, but he realized that when we hear
it in Batman vs Superman, wonder woman has already grown into a confident
warrior, so it makes sense that her theme
is warlike and well-developed in it's
superhero confidence, but this movie is
Diana's origin story. It's about her
transitioning into this superhero. So for
the first hour of the movie, Williams
crafted new music for Diana which he
described as feminine, but underpinned
with percussion and propulsion. He wanted it to build into a crescendo as Diana
increasingly learns about the darkness
of the world around her, until she
decides to take action. Then, the pivotal
turning point happens when Diana crosses
into no-man's land, and once she gets to
the other side, Williams waits until this
precise moment to finally hit us with
Zimmer's theme, an hour and 17 minutes in,
right as Diana jumps into the German controlled building and tears him apart.
This is the exact moment that we see
Diana transform into a full superhero, as
she is in Batman or Superman.
So, naturally we hear Guo's electric
cello shred through the scene as well. So,
if you like me found yourself applauding
during the sequence, this thoughtful
creativity and strategic timing with the
music might have been a big reason why.
Do you think the one-woman theme is too
familiar?
Seriously, I won't judge. Or do you think
the movie could have used this theme
more? And a question that I'm really
curious about - what current movie
superhero do you think could use a new
theme song of their own? Like I don't
know if I need Hulk and Thor to each
have their own iconic melodies like wonder  woman does, but I definitely wouldn't
mind it. Honestly, weigh in. Let me know
what you think in the comments, and if
you like this kind of detail-obsessed
analysis in this video, I go into the
secret stories behind a ton of other
stuff in Wonder Woman. Missable Easter
eggs to the Wonder Woman history, and
other classic films it might surprise
you how they inspire this movie, and a bunch
of subtle connections to history and
Greek mythology, and that's all in my
in-depth Wonder Woman full movie
breakdown, so go check that out. And I
love doing these deep, crazy dives into
music and the TV shows and movies that I
love, and if you like it too, again like
this video and share it with your friends,
because I feel like not enough people
are talking about this. And definitely
subscribe because we've done this with
stuff like Game of Thrones, and Star Wars,
Guardians of the Galaxy. We cover a ton
of different stuff on this channel. And
you can help us make more of these kind
of videos and even have a say and what
those videos are by contributing to new
rockstars on patreon. Huge thanks to all
of our current donors, especially you
Kelly Hopper. Kelly, you're so great. And
definitely hit me up on Twitter (@eavoss) with all
your thoughts about this music and
anything Wonder Woman related or
anything at all, honestly. You can also
follow new rockstars on Twitter
(@newrockstars) and for those of you cool
enough to still be watching, let's
compose a new theme song for Hulk right
now. Drop me a beat.
Hulk and Thor, they're best friends gonna keep you
watching until the credits end...
Um, actually no.